as all Marvel fans know Groot is a
character who's more about action than
he is about talk possessing only a
handful of words in his vocabulary that
can be understood by humans the tree
like superhero hasn't said much else
other than I am Groot and we are Groot
throughout his time in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe of course each line
apparently has a translation hey you
have some acorns on you kid for example
James Gunn revealed that groots final
line to Rocket Raccoon just before
crumbling into space dust in Avengers
infinity war translated to quote dad
because that ending wasn't sad enough
already and now keeping up with what
seems like a new tradition Marvel gave
Groot another intriguing final line in
Avengers end game directors Joe and
Anthony Russo revealed what the talking
tree boy said at the very end of
Avengers endgame when they spoke in a
Q&A session following a screening of the
superhero ensemble at the Smithsonian
National Air and Space Museum in
Washington DC a reddit user who was in
attendance detailed the Russos answers
to nearly two dozen questions one of
which regarded Groot and the final words
he uttered in endgame the last place fan
saw Groot in Avengers end game was
aboard the spaceship Benatar watching a
star-lord and Thor have a friendly but
maybe not so friendly squabble the two
heroes exchanged some jabs that they
pass off his jokes before Drax the
destroyer chimes in and suggests they
fight one another for the honor of
leadership after the other Guardians
voiced their support for a knife fight
the camera then pans over to Groot who
smiles and says I am Groot according to
the Russo brothers that line genuinely
means something it translates from
groots native language into English as
quote yes I like knives so there you
have it the entire guardians of the
galaxy squad wants star-lord and Thor to
settle their differences in a down and
dirty knife fight including little greet
he likes to play with knives very well
we shall indulge him while groots final
line in avengers endgame isn't nearly as
significant as the last word he said in
Avengers infinity war that doesn't mean
the phrase is completely without meaning
in its own regard
groots last endgame line leaves things
with the guardians of the galaxy on a
happy silly note which in turn
establishes the tone for the next entry
in the team's film trilogy group joining
in on the banter with the rest of the
gang proves that the guardians are back
in good spirits after Thanos's original
decimation in 2018 and the reverse snap
professor Hulk executed an endgame the
team may be without Gamora
who got tossed over a cliff on Vermeer
so her dad could get a rock but they've
finally reassembled and are ready to
locate their missing member this last
sequence for the guardians and end game
teases that they may go on a search for
Gamora and guardians of the galaxy vol 3
which would probably benefit from having
Thor in tow so long as he and star-lord
can squash the beef between them as
unlikely as that seems at the moment you
know Thor yeah tall guy not that
good-looking needed saving it'll be
interesting to see how the god of
thunder and the Lord of dance get on in
the third guardians movie well their
apparent rivalry dissipate before it
gets out of hand or will it continue to
grow until they have no choice but to
sharpen their knives for a one-on-one
fight thus satisfying the twisted wishes
of the rest of the team in the process
star-lord may have the advantage of a
sweet dance moves that shimmy and Shake
around the hammer wielding hero and
knowing quill you might even play by
Butch Cassidy rules someone count one
two three go watch this Rico on the
other hand Thor is a God who can summon
literal lightning if the two were to
ever really turn their verbal stabs into
literal ones Thor would probably end up
winning you know as long as he goes for
the head check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about Avengers end game are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]